and I ain't got nothing to do I probably
sit there all day and play we be in a
party about 16 deep all day and we just
be running for about 12 hours on this
game
[Music]
before I always make my players
left-handed 68 small
forward first we going to start with the
acceleration then we going to go to
blocking all right we go to get this
three
ball y'all see these Shades oh you know
Jimmy being and Jason Tatum now jeral
Wallace when I play in real life I play
like d Mitch definitely I used to I used
to have bunnies but I can't jump like I
used
to I like the new city mainly like the
stores cuz they give you more options
like a lot a lot of clothes a lot of
different stuff you can get Graphics get
better the city get
bigger all right just got some drip from
swags about to head
to jump man put some kicks on I'm a real
big sneaker head so I've been um been in
the shoes for a long time one of the
reasons why I wear Jordans on the
field um try to get a little creative
when I you know when I'm putting shoes
on for
sure I really didn't like football
growing up I was really like a
basketball player I think that's kind of
why I like playing basketball game for
real I used to just play football game
before playing 2K I used to really suck
and then I I got really good by playing
with you know other people and now like
everybody be want to run with me all the
time so I used to play basketball a lot
but I don't think I ever play an NBA
Celebrity game cuz sometimes I feel like
they be going too hard I ain't got time
for
it all right we squatted up yeah it is
kind of cool like meet new people on the
game and just be able to play the game
with him it's just crazy like the uh
like you can really like make friends on
this
game hey I also like the uh the
crossplay cuz I I know a good bit of
people that say like the Xbox players
better than PlayStation players which I
think it's fraud cuz I ain't lost to
Xbox player yet oh and then one dude
ain't even playing a few times I run
into a few NBA players on the game I ran
the uh PG in there like a a week or so
ago and he was ball
hogging
oh no defense no
nothing